vous avez vu hier il ya 58 kinsa ils ont
annoncé les débuts des travaux de la
star ac va revenir ils ont d'ailleurs
l'indien bombay une info monsieur jp la
cause sera officiellement fait ça le cpe
alors à priori a priori donc oui tout va
bien sous tout avance bien voilà ça sera
sont mal barrés les gosses et pauvres
quand même un carré danse avec arrêt a
été ré alors parce qu'ils feront près
les mêmes joueurs comme moi justement la
question qu'on va se poser c'est est-ce
que vous y croyez ou non à ce retour ça
fait évidemment les belles heures les
grandes heures de tf1 avec des records
d'audience un peu 12 millions on verra
les scores après vous avez un petit
récap est juste en dessus du lot après
fin non c'était bien rester au dessus du
lot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les portes du château de la star academy
vont bientôt ouvrir soyez le bienvenu à
star académie il ya plusieurs semaines
tf1 confirmé la rumeur en diffusant une
bande annonce exclusive afin de recruter
ses futurs académiciens
je passe l'anonymat total à la lumière
qui brûle tout sur son passage 21 ans
après la première saison qui a déréglé
jennifer
la première star academy
nouvelle saison d'avoir le jour prof
nouvelle directrice nouveau plateau n'ya
l'animation pas de changement ni cause
devraient bien présenter cette neuvième
saison sur tf1 aujourd'hui c'est le
grand soir le retour de la star ac aly
marque aussi le retour de la télé
d'enfermement les académiciens pourrait
sans doute retrouver l'emblématique
château de dammarie les lys dans
quelques heures les 16 candidats de la
star academy vont arriver bref vous
l'avez compris l'école de chant la plus
prisée france est de retour alors croyez
vous au tour de la star ac
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant parce que alors tu parlais
20 vous vous parle il a cru en nous non
non non pense que tu toi dans la vie
c'est vrai que la star ac a mieux marché
que loft langue c'est pareil c'était de
grands démissionner mais le point commun
entre elles c'est que ni pour mon
émission ni pour la star ac en fait
personne voulait animer la star ac ils
ont proposé à tous les animateurs de tf1
dont les podiums j'ai manqué qui a
refusé et moi mon époque quand ils m'ont
appelé pour faire le loft vous parez
vous n'êtes tout paris avait refusé il y
avait quelqu'un c'est le compost et
c'était moi le vif taille le pij et oui
je le faisais surtout besoin de bosser à
l'époque où
j'étais j'ai pas tellement réfléchi mais
dans lequel nikos il était chroniqueur
chez
tous bateaux avec très peu d'expérience
et pour le coup était lancé dans un bain
absolument incroyable croyez-vous retour
de la star ac oui non oui non alors il
ya que de nom et oui
j'ai gardé ce nom tous les oui sont des
incompétents
expliquer pourquoi c'est une calamité
annoncé une calamité parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus de talent
comme ça on va créer des faux talent
qu'on va tenter de faire émerger les
vrais talents sont sur les réseaux
sociaux ils n'ont pas besoin de
l'astarac qu'un produit qui flirte sur
l'effet nostalgie en a ras-le-bol etc on
va les remettre à dammarie les lys où il
ya plein de travaux parce qu'on sait pas
où les mettre alors on tente de refaire
ce qu'on a déjà fait à la fin de la star
ac c'était un naufrage donc la
même table sur nrj12 et non non alors je
défende mathieu se raidir des deux amis
un million deux se désole c'était très
bien wen et rendons à césar ce qui est à
césar oui soyons honnêtes c'est vrai
voilà donc effectivement 12 millions
saison une voyez comme sa grille clean
non mais globalement à temps quand tu es
à 12 11 10 9 8 8 voilà bon à près de 6,2
ça reste et 5,9 aujourd'hui au score des
jeux et à ce niveau les cils tous les
jolis mais ça veut dire longtemps alors
on va faire une émission quotidienne
hebdomadaire
c'est l'histoire de mathieu laigle
pamiers mais bon c'est pas
volontairement à mes amis l'un d'eux
pour pour nrj nationale et souhaiterait
bien été colossal et c'est un vieux
produit pas faire ma ça marchera jamais
alors il alors faire une hebdo une
quotidienne alors il va débarquer
40 du lundi au vendredi le prime sera
sûrement le vendredi c'est vraiment une
partie sur tmc une partie sur téléfoot
sur tf1 tout ce qui est un peu dommage
il côtoya lundi 24 ans sont 24 ans
vivrait ces personnes n'ont pas du tout
si toi tu es une grande critique
télévisuelle et ça le monde entier le
sait ah je rigole si tu dis justement on
va les enfermer
dumas star du programme et ça tout le
monde va te le dire c'est le château et
c'est un bon point qu'on vient d'un
château parce que l'essence même de la
star academy c'est le château isolé ni
ailleurs je t'aurais dit ça ne marche
pas et aujourd'hui c'est pas que les
réseaux sociaux il ya des jeunes qui
veulent chanter il faut leur donner la
chance et si l'on le château avec moi je
pense que ça peut fondre dans le château
est en travaux où on a les images c'est
et à une salle d'hier soir
racheté par un nouveau propriétaire à la
fin de la star academy le château
n'avait pas été rénovée depuis
l or il ya encore du travail avant de
voir arriver les prochains académiciens
[Musique]
de formidables deux ans on va changer un
petit peu la disposition des pièces on
l'a tout redécorer et les lieux n'ont
pas fini de révéler leurs secrets
les deux producteurs ont encore quelques
vestiges à découvrir
[Musique]
et
de compléter les malheurs qui n'affiche
aucun travaux et défendre face aux
petits oignons avec haine des vols cette
première poule un problème depuis qu'il
a acheté énormément kepler
l'administration variés des rénovations
avorté et c'est pour lui c'est
l'opération de la dernière chance à
basque et c'est un château classé quand
même je crois avait donc on peut pas
faire ce qu'on veut oui mais d'ici là
j'ai une question très importante moi je
pense je suis comme vous mitigé si les
candidats n'ont aucun téléphone et ne
peuvent pas communiquer sur les réseaux
je pense que dans ce cas précis les gens
iront naturellement sur la somme des
épisodes qui peuvent communiquer sa ne
marche ra jamais alors je sais pas ce
qui va se passer il vous est sûrement
dans la boucle alors nous tous non je ne
suis pas dans la boucle oui mais oui
il faut merci merci mongie non mais
andré tu critiques tout le temps les
gens sur les enfants les influenceurs
sur les réseaux sociaux et là tu dis non
mais ils sont déjà sur les réseaux ils
sont très bien donc il faut ne pas les
mettre là bas mais en fait faut ni les
maîtres laban les médecins à t'écouter
donc à un moment donné c'est très bien
moi qui suis une grande amatrice de télé
réalité j'ai hâte parce que enfin ça va
redonner de la fraîcheur à la télé
réalité vraiment en plus c'est un
programme qui était un mythe c'est à
dire c'est un programme qui est émis
chick et je suis très content de le
retrouver avec un peu de modernité etc
et c'est bien des concours de talent je
trouve au contraire c'est très bien on
peut pas aller contre des des talents en
fait vous dites que latéralité c'est des
gens souvent qui font un peu tout et
n'importe quoi là vous avez des gens qui
ont un truc inventé un truc à donner
d'eux-mêmes à plein des trams en rien ce
mot c'est incroyable talent
m6 sont vénales emmerder qui savent rien
faire
je vous trouve un peu dur alors
apparemment ils vont garder la rive du
téléphone ces minutes par jour oui notez
ce qu'on n'y a pas de téléphone portable
qui seront vraiment courir à ses plans
dans ce cas là haut mais ça peut ça peut
fonctionner qu'en mai après nous dans la
une y avait eu un téléphone mario avait
plein de cannes téléphone donc il va
bien falloir
messieurs voilà l'été vous avez
prométhéen mettez un brouilleur fait
comme nous dans le lob mais oui à briand
était pas de preuve alors de quoi vous
n'y croyez pas non plus mais moi je suis
je suis surpris par votre action parce
que pour moi c'est une autre télévision
c'est une télévision sans rythme où il
se passe pas grand chose en réalité où
on va chercher à créer justement parler
de buzz tout à l'heure on cherche à
créer du buzz en permanence en enfermant
des gens dans un château et après sur le
sur la télévision où je suis désolé il
s'est passé quand même beaucoup de
choses en 14 ans vous avez the voice
vous avez plein de formes and now
panorama qui sont arrivées sur les
antennes de télévision je trouve que
c'est un manque d'audace un manque de
courage d'aller rechercher une émission
comme la star ac la star ac si vous
faites juste un événement un one shot en
prime pourquoi pas mais enfin c'est
comme si demain vous me disais tiens on
va faire le retour de champs elysées on
va faire le recul
j'ai terrain marche pas parce que la
télévision elle a évolué à évoluer les
codes ont évolué aujourd'hui comparé
star ac as the voice ou même avec la
nouvelle c'est la campagne c'est avant
tout la même télé vitré c'est pas paris
les téléspectateurs aussi ils ont bougé
en 14 ans mais ce que les gens sont
inquiets de le voir ils ont alors
demandé aubry qui veut aller regarder
cette émission de télévision à moi
c'est mes bd revient à regarder voilà
il se soit 5 millions 9 alors je pense
on arrive à ce public très jeune donc
c'est 1000 cc plutôt bien
alors excusez moi y'a qu'à vous regardez
donc
vous savez quoi
et vous n'êtes pas à l'abri que ce soit
un peu en dessous de the voice en
résultat de vol c'est à 4 millions à 3
millions
5,6 x et
iphone 4 millions sur millions 3
millions star ac n'en millions 10
millions da il se rend compte moi le
premier en france renforce aussi vous
verrez ce que je vous dis oui le début
de mai on aime les madeleines de proust
moyenne de prout moi on sait jamais
entendu à ce niveau là vous et moi et ça
m'a pas changé et nicolas
malheureusement des fois quand on entend
parler vaincu rejoint gilles et ça fait
un peu vieille et gris et c'est dommage
parce qu'en fait tu sais pas quoi
polhenri actionnaires c'est tout ce qui
fait rire c'est la modernité
vous vivez dans votre brosse effet
louette modèle
barça angels on est plutôt mal barré moi
je vous explique je pense qu'un talent n
cho et c'est la raison pour laquelle
america's got talent c'est tout ça à
magog ça continue à performer on a
besoin de voir la création d'un talent n
cho moi j'ai envie de les voir quand ils
partent dans leurs cours de chant quand
ils vont faire le théâtre quand ils vont
répéter leur chorégraphie
j'ai envie de voir la naissance de
nouveaux talents je veux les suivre même
24 sur 24
voilà moi j'ai envie de les voir et de
d'avoir des rendez-vous en plateau
chaque semaine et c'est peut être ce qui
manque aussi un place de vols ce qui
fait que le programme suse autant parce
qu'on l'ait on ne veut plus rouge voilà
on vit pas au quotidien avec eux et moi
alors par rapport à ce que magali m
c'est vrai dans la téléréalité moi c'est
tout ce que j'aime dans la télé réalité
c'est à dire comme à l'époque d'à star
académie c'était quelque chose de sain
ils étaient ils étaient neuf s'il était
nouveau il n'était pas là pour devenir
des superstars et faire des bad buzz il
était surtout là pour montrer ce qu'ils
avaient dans leur halle la grande
question sur l'édition
star académie
pourra-t-il s'offrir le même stack à
l'époque à la rosa s'est résumée à ce
qu'ils ont l'air et son père de star à
lui sinon regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
disons que c'est mal
celui ci
je sais pas qui ont les mêmes casting
vous dire une chose c'est que je pense
sincèrement que le succès de la star ac
n'est pas dû aux invités prestigieux
mais efekta quant aux candidats bien sûr
d'amour au fait qu'ils ont ils ont
commencé comme une téléréalité puis
c'est devenu une vraie merci mais
c'est un ami à moi c'est aussi beaucoup
d'ambition et qu'ils ont commencé comme
une télé réalité et puis après
l'excellent art joubert a compris que
c'était à la fois un talk show est un
peu de télé réalité c'est un parfait
mélange n'est pas lui mais ce serait
bien si un thé tout nouveau camp rocco
quand la star à qui est arrivé on était
après le loft c'est lé nouveau qu il ne
s'agissait pas ça intéressait les gens
de regarder ce qui pourrait se passer
c'était tout nouveau aujourd'hui ce
qu'on a envie de regarder exactement ce
qu'on a vu à l'époque regarde les scores
de la une cet appétit la une au début ça
n'a pas marché il faut savoir que la
star ac ne marchait pas les salariés
attendent et on avait d'abord été ceux à
touristes je pense que non seulement ça
n'a pas marché mais il c'est la question
d'aller jouer à une semaine oui qu'ils
arrêtent et un désastre total et sirène
finale de rugby qui permet les ménagères
mais est tournée des as france télé pour
aller vers tf1 le programme ça rêve mais
on n'a pas eu tous ces artistes allaient
non mais dans ce cas là deux et ça a
fonctionné mais en tout cas je pense que
ça va pas apporter effectivement de la
fraîcheur comme tu disais à la télé
parce que mais en revanche ça va
apporter de la nostalgie et on assume
qu'on aime la nostalgie est sûr
personnellement mois dans le programme
ce que j'aime le plus c'est de savoir
que jean pascal il est dedans parce que
moi quand j'étais petit je regardais
[Applaudissements]
évidemment le ballon il a fait une
chanson billie on est à égalité
et vous disent et on verra bien en tous
les cas je pense qu'effectivement la
présence de jean pascal
je pense qu'ils ont intérêt à rappeler
aussi d'autres l'isaf écrit tim mon avis
mais c'est pas encore des apparences et
pas du tout décidé comme directrice et
l'a dit la directrice on évoque le nom
de lara fabian qui a été au québec en
2020 et 2021 directrice de la star ac
serait bien passé et là elle va
peut-être le faire c'est sylvie tellier
a refusé mais très bien merci pour cette
info